Arkadaşlar merhaba Bugün 3 başlık
altında konuşmak istiyorum birincisi
felsefe ne işe yarar ikincisi felsefe ve
inanç sorununu nasıl ele almamız
gerekiyor üçüncüsü Evrensel sorunlara
nasıl yaklaşılmalıdır
sevinçle şunu önce vurgulamak istiyorum
son yıllarda ülkemizde felsefeye olan
ilgi gözle görülür bir şekilde artmıştır
Bunun kanaatince iki önemli nedeni var
toplumsal verisi
oldukça ağırlaşmıştır İkincisi ise son
yıllarda siyasal İslamın etkisindeki
genç nüfusun ve özellikle de üniversite
üzerinde inanç meselesine yaklaşımının
artmış olmasıdır bu tabi sevindirici bir
durumdur felsefe tarihine baktığımızda
da büyük filozofların siyasi dini ve
kültürel krizler döneminde özellikle Bu
dönemlerde ortaya çıktıklarını
ve kendi tezler
açtıklarını görüyoruz
Peki kısaca Felsefe nedir bu konuya
girmek istiyorum felsefe kelime itibari
ile bilgelik sevgisidir Yani filozofya
bizim Yunancadan bildiğimiz filozofya
iki bölümden oluşur birincisi fil
dostluk demektir ikincisi Sofya
kökeni Mısır gizemciliği ne kadar giden
bilgelik tanrıçasıdır Ancak ben tabii
bilgelik sevgisi ifadesini Aslında çok
beğenmiyorum desem daha doğru olur çok
fazla bir şey ifade etmiyor O nedenle
başka bir tanım kullanmak istiyorum
felsefe kanınca insanın sınırlı bilgisi
ile evrenin sınırsız bilgisine kafa
tutmasıdır Yani insan
her zaman insanın bilgisi sınırlıdır
evrenin bilgisi ise sınırsızdır bu
çelişkiye İnsanoğlu kafa tutar ve şimdi
esas felsefenin bu olduğunu anlatmak
istiyorum Peki bu ne demektir Yani bu
insanın sınırlı bilgisi ile evrenin
sınırsız bilgisine kafa tutması ne
demektir
bölümden oluşuyor dikkat ederseniz
birincisi insanın bilgisinin sınırlı
olduğu tezi iki evrenin bilgisinin
sınırsız olduğu tezi yani aralarında bir
çatışma var dikkat ederseniz 3 insanın
evrenin sonsuzu bilgisine kafa tutması
hiçbir zaman da bitmeyecek bir durum
gibi gözüküyor biliyorsunuz Yunan
mitolojisinde sizi fosfö eğlencesi var
yani Tanrılar tarafından cezalandırılan
sisipos sürekli bir kayayı kendinden
büyük bir kayayı tepelerin tepeye
çıkarır fakat tepeye ulaştırdığı anda o
Kaya yeniden tepenin alt kısmına doğru
yuvarlanarak
sürekli taşımak zorunda kalır insanın
durumu da aslında böyledir insan
kaybedeceğini bile bile bir mücadeleye
atılır çünkü hayat budur Peki insanın
bilgisi neden sınırlıdır bu sorunu biraz
eşcinim istersiniz
birincisi insanın
hem Zihni kapasitesi sınırlıdır hem de
ömrü kısadır zihninizin kapasitesi
devasa büyüklükte Ve ömrümüz de Binlerce
yıl sürseydi bile evrenin bilgisi ile
boy ölçüşecek durumda olamazdı Çünkü
evrenin yapı taşı olan madde yani varlık
Sürekli hareket halindedir ve her
değiştiği anda kendisi ile birlikte
bilgiyi de değişikliğe uğratmaktadır
yani o hareket
maddenin özünü oluşturan hareket sürekli
olduğu için bilgi de sürekli
değişmektedir bunu ünlü filozof heraklit
şöyle ifade etmişti bir nehirde iki kez
yıkanılmaz Peki bu ne demektir bununla
evrenin her an değiştiğini ve
yıkandığını suyun da akıp gittiğini
yeniden nehre girildiğinde ise başka bir
suyla karşı karşıya olduğumuzu
söylemişti Fakat ben bunun bile eksik
olduğunu zannediyorum
çünkü Eğer o su akıp gitmemiş olsaydı
bile yıkandığımız su eski su Olmazdı
çünkü kullandığımız suyun kimyası çoktan
değişmiş olacaktı Kısacası bilgimiz her
an eskidiği için evrenin sonsuz ve
sürekli değişen bilgisine hiçbir zaman
erişemeyeceğiz maddenin değişim hızı
bizim bilgi edinme hızımızdan kat ve kat
fazladır evrenin bilgisi sonsuz olmasına
rağmen merakımız da son bulmamaktadır
Çünkü insan merak eden sorunların deşip
sorgulayan ve işin köküne varıncaya
kadar huzur bulamayan canlı bir
varlıktır merak duygusunun kökeni ise
kuşkusuz bilgiye olan ihtiyaçtan
kaynaklanır Yani bir şeyi merak
etmemizin temel nedeni Aslında
o bilgiye olan ihtiyacımızdır
ve bu ise sonsuzdur yaşam enerjimizin
kaynağı da işte Bu bilgiye ulaşma arzusu
ve ben buna da bilgisizliğimize sürekli
kafa tutmak diyorum yani insan
kendisinin az bilgisine az bilgisiyle
yetinmez Sürekli yeni bilgi edinmek
isterler Fakat o edineceği bilginin
devasa olması
bunu bildiğimiz halde bu savaştan da bu
mücadelenin de vazgeçmez
Peki insan felsefeye neden ihtiyaç duyar
biraz da bu meseleye değinmek istiyorum
felsefenin tarihten gelen bazı temel
kuralları ve yöntemleri vardır bunlar;
bir Emin olmadığımız konular ve durumlar
hakkında sürekli soru sorarız 2 bize
söylenen Emin olmadığımız herhangi bir
şeyin Niçin öyle değil de böyle
olduğundan her zaman şüphe duyuyoruz 3
doğruluğundan şüphe edilen iddiaları her
zaman akıl süzgecinden geçiririz 4
içinde yaşadığımız ve çoğunlukla memnun
olmadığınız mevcut durum hakkında
Geleceğe dair tasavvurlarda bulunuyoruz
Yani herhangi bir insan yoktur ki
geleceği ile ilgili tasavvurularda
planlarda planlar geliştirilmesini
tasavvurularda bulunmasın bu 4 ana madde
Aslında felsefeye olan ihtiyaçtan
kaynaklanmaktadır dikkat edersek Her
insan kendi yaşamını sorular şüphe
duyarak konuları araştırarak bunları
yaparken de akla başvurarak ve gelecekte
nasıl bir durumda olmak istediğine
ilişkin düşünceler düşünceler İnşa
ederek ilerler
felsefenin hayatımızda doğrudan ilişkisi
vardır
felsefe Salt birçok insanın iddia ettiği
gibi sadece Tefekkür değildir merak
değildir mi yani meditasyon değildir
Aksine ihtiyaç duyduğumuz bilgilere
erişme mücadelesidir diyebiliriz
şimdi peki felsefe ne işe yarar dedik ve
bunu nasıl uyguluyoruz hayatımızda
felsefe bize en başta soyutlamayı
öğretir yani kavram üretmemizi sağlar
bir Örnek vermek gerekirse soyutlama
düşünmeyi kolaylaştırır onlarca ağaç
çeşidini saymamak için biz orman terimi
kullanırız veya Ayşe Can Emel Deniz gibi
isimleri Yani tek tek şahıslarda
ifadesini bulan isimleri saymamak için
topluca insan deriz kavramlar yaratarak
düşünmeyi kısaltır ve kolaylaştırmış
oluruz gördüğümüz gibi felsefenin en
önemli özelliklerinden biri düşünmeyi
kolaylaştırmış olmasıdır
bize felsefe kavramları nasıl
kullanacağınızı da öğretir olay ve
durumları bize göründüğü gibi değil
derinde yatan anlamıyla değerlendirmeyi
öğretir Yani biz çoğunlukla yüzeysel
konulara baktığınızda Aslında o
olayların manasını olayların nedenlerini
kavrayamayız işte felsefe bize daha
derinden bakmayı öğretiyor arkadaşlar
felsefe bize karmaşık gözüken
sorunlarımızı belli bir sıralama içinde
ele almaya da öğretir en önemlisinden
başlamayı Yani bizim birçok sorunlarımız
oluyor Tabi önemli sorunlarımız önemsiz
sorunlarımız işte felsefe bize en önemli
sorundan başlamayı ikinci Önemli olan
sorunların da eğer birinci önemli sorunu
çözüldüğünde kendiliğinden çözüleceğini
anlatır ve kapatır yani felsefe bize
sistemli düşünmeyi sorunlara sistemini
yaklaşmayı öğretir felsefe düşünmenin
aslında bir ustalık işi olduğunu Neyi
nasıl ve hangi yöntemle ele almamız
gerektiğinde öğretir
Dolayısıyla felsefe bize konuların nasıl
basitleştirileceğini kabul ettir Ayrıca
felsefe bize yaşamın nasıl anlamlı veya
anlamsız olacağını da öğretir bize
değerler sisteminin anlamını öğretir
Şimdi mesela kibirli mi olacağız
mütevazim olacağız Açgözlü mü olacağız
cömertme olacağız gaddar mı olacağız
vicdanlı mı olacağız tüketim hastası mı
olacağız veya kanaatkâr
seçenekler konusunda bizim
tercihlerde bulunmanızı sağlayacak dedi
biz buna değerler sisteminde doğru olanı
seçme yöntemi diyoruz Kısacası felsefe
etik değerlerimizin doğru olup
olmadığını doğru değilse hangi değerleri
benimsememiz ve onları hayatınızda
uygulamamız gerektiğini de kapatır
Halil Cibran ruhumuz bir savaş alanı
gibidir der mantığımız tutkularımız
arzularımız ve amaçlarımız çoğunlukla
birbirine karışır işte felsefe bize bu
karmaşık durumdan çıkmaya da yardımcı
olur
peki
felsefenin din ile ilişkisine bakalım
dinler nasıl ortaya çıktı ve evrensel
sorunlara nasıl
yararlanıyorlar veya verebiliyorlar mı
insanlar nasıl İnanır neden İnanır bunu
açıklayabilmek için biraz geriye gitmek
gerekiyor hayvanların bilincinde doğa ve
biz kavramı yoktur onlar böyle bir ayrım
yapmaz yani doğanın bağrında yaşarlar
fakat ona yabancılaşmadan yaşarlar
insanlar ise doğada yabancılaşarak Yani
onun bir parçası olmakla birlikte onunla
Özdeş olmadıklarını bilerek mi
kavrayarak ayrışırlar kendilerini
doğadan soyutlarlar insan beyni
metafizik üreten bir alettir Peki bu ne
demektir O olmayanı düşünmek yok Olanı
zihinde var etmek
sanatın edebiyatın mitolojinin dinlerin
masalların gelecek tasavvurlarının
kökeni buradadır dikkat ederseniz
bunların hepsinde Aslında var olmayan
şeyler tasavvur edilmektedir
olmayanı düşünen ilk insan
anlattığı masallarla
hikayelerle
başkaları üzerinden nasıl etkili
olduğunu görmüştür
Eğer anlattığımızda İnsanların
gözlerinin parladığını hüzünlendiğini
Sevinç duyduklarını hissederiz
Dolayısıyla Bu etkinin gücüdür ki
İnsanoğlu Hayret eder merak eder
öfkelenir Rıza gösterir harekete geçer
veya bir
insan etkinin sadece canlı varlıklar
üzerinde değil aynı zamanda cansız
varlıklar üzerinde de etkili olduğunu
düşünmüştür ilk anlarda Bu yüzden her
varlıkta görülemeyen hissedilemeyen bir
ruh aramıştır Yani bizim göremediğimiz
bir ruhun olduğu varsayılmıştır
şamanlardan biliriz ağaçlarla
kartallarla rüzgarlarla ve atlarla
Konuşurlar ilahilerle şarkılarla
dualarla onları kendilerine boyun
eğdireceklerini zanırlar
onlara şükreder onlara öfkelenir onlara
biat ederler ama onlara dua yoluyla
dileklerini de kabul ettireceklerine
inanırlar Kısacası insan hayvanlar
aleminden kendilerine Tanrılar yaratarak
uzaklaşmıştır Tanrı nedir
Tanrı en iyi en mükemmel en yaratıcı En
kusursuz varlık imgesi değil midir İnsan
hep en kusursuzu en yaratıcı ve en iyi
varlık olmak istememiş midir ve böylece
ideal bir varlık varlığı da kendine idol
olarak
benimdir ilerleyen süreçte bu düşünce
önce Çok tanrılı dinlere yani
şamanlardan başlarsak önce çok Tanrı
dinlere işte Yunan döneminde Yunan
felsefesinde buna çok rastlıyoruz
mitolojisinde çok rastlıyoruz ve
ardından da tek tanrı dinlere
evrilmiştir dinler özellikle semavi
dinler imparatorlukların iddiaları
olarak ortaya çıktılar Yani onların
hedefleri amaçları olarak ortaya
çıktılar dinlerin temelinde ilahi
yasalarla gerekçelendirilmiş ahlaki
ilkeler Örneğin öldürmeyeceksin
zulmetmeyeceksin yetim hakkı
yemeyeceksin zina etmeyeceksin gibi
ilkeler bulunur
hem Yahudilik hem Hristiyanlık hem de
İslam dini bu ülkeler üzerine
kurulduğunu ileri sürer dinler ortaçağ
imparatorluklarının Fetih
politikalarının gerekçesi olarak belli
bir yere kadar etki alanlarını
genişletmişlerdir Bu yüzden sadece bir
kavmin ya da bir bölgenin değil bütün
insanlık aleminin dinleri oldukları
ileri sürmüşlerdir Dolayısıyla
insanların Evrensel sorunlarının da
Nihayet çözümü dinlerde yaptığını
söylemişlerdir ancak ne kölelik bitmiş
Ne zalimlikler sorunu bulmuştur aksine
fetihlerle birlikte Bunlar daha da
artmıştır
kölelerinin sayıları artmış
zalimliklerde artmıştır başta vaat
edilen iddialar önemli ölçüde boşa
çıkmıştır bütün bu bir Evrensel sorunlar
öyle bir boyut kazanmıştır ki bırakalım
dinlerin bunlara yanıt vermesini Bu
sorunlara ilişkin ciddi bir kavrayışın
bile olmadığını İleri sürebiliriz
ne yazık ki dinler son 30-40 yılda
özellikle son yıllarda Bunu daha çok
görüyoruz o kadar aydınlanmaya rağmen o
kadar Rönesans
fikirlerine rağmen hümanizmaya rağmen
hala kültürler arası savaşın çatışmanın
ve savaşların aracı olarak
kullanılmaktadır
insanlığın büyük sorunlarına felsefenin
yaklaşımı ne olabilir veya önce
insanlığın büyük sorunları hangileridir
karınca felsefenin işleri sadece
sorgulamak değil aynı zamanda Geleceğe
dair tasavvurularda bulunmaktır
insanlığın Baş belası olan üç temel
sorun vardır ki bunlara ben kısaca
modern cehalet demeyi uygun görüyor
Bunlar nelerdir Bir
dünyanın ozon tabakasını delen iklim
dengesini bozan bütün canlılara ait olan
temiz havayı akciğerlerimiz olan
ormanları binbir türlü canlı varlığını
yaşam alanı olan denizleri ve doğal
zenginlikleri kar hırsı ve tüketim
hastalığı yüzünden bitirme noktasına
getiren küresel cehalet 2 gelişmiş
kapitalist ülkelerin marifetiyle
tahakküm ve sömürden kaynaklanan küresel
eşitsizliğin ve gelir adaletsizliğin yol
açtığı küresel sefalet açlık salgın ve
eğitimsizlikten kaynaklanan kültürel
cehalet 3 ülke içinde bizim ülkemizde
söz konusudur işte bir ülke içinde
toplumsal siyasal çoğulculuğu yok eden
din kültürü ve düşünceden kaynaklı
farklılıkları Bir kültürel zenginlik
olarak değil Aksine Bir tehlike olarak
gören ve bölgeler ayırırsa arası
ayrımcılığı
ırkçılığı cinsiyetçiliği ve özellikle
ikinciliği sürekli fışkırtarak
toplumları bölen toplumsal cehalet
diyorum arkadaşlar görüldüğü gibi
felsefenin
sadece kendi hayatımızı ilgili değil ama
aynı zamanda insanlığın temel
sorunlarına ilişkin de önemli
tasavvuruları var ve önemli
projeksiyonlar tutuyor bu üç alan
kanınca Önümüzdeki dönemde insanlığın
temel sorunları olacaktır Ve bu
sorunlara verilecek yanıt da felsefenin
başarılı olup olmamasının sınavı
olacaktır beni dinlediğiniz için
teşekkür ederim arkadaşlar sunumun bu
kadar